[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report at presented by
fanduel we are just one week away from
the playoffs
i'm greg ivory alongside the man
the myth the legend sam richmond are you
ready for the playoffs brother
i'm so excited man i feel like we've
been talking it for a while playoffs are
coming up now we are finally a week away
it's it's exciting man i'm pumped
it's very exciting but as always we're
giving away locks we're giving away
hoodies and we're giving away jerseys
but do not forget i've got some brand
new br betting basketball shorts and i'm
giving those away as well get in the
comments everybody because i need gifts
i need emojis but most importantly sam
we on this show we need winners
only
please and in fact i'm giving out some
of those shorts
right now i am in the comments
looking to see who is here and i see
sean griffin sean griffin says
take giannis rebounds and he gave us
some uh emojis uh there you guys see it
on the screen he's also 2-0 on the
nerfey so sean you deserve
those uh br betting shorts that i don't
have and i need to actually get them but
sam it's tnt thursday which means
we are betting the three by two the
question is will there be two
three-pointers in the first three
minutes of the game i need all of you to
get in the comments and tell me which
3x2 is a lock sam talk to me talk to the
people
what are you thinking
yeah i leaned towards the bucks celtics
one look there's a lot of guys out
tonight but i think uh there's still
enough stars in that buck celtics game
some really good shooters uh hopefully
chris middleton uh can lead the way and
get it done for us tonight
sam sam is rocking sam is rocking uh but
let me go to the comments and see if the
comments are rocking with sam and the
milwaukee bucks in that boston celtics
game uh i see i see big bet in the
comments shout out to you big bet uh
sean griffin
i also see
uh
[Music]
duke smith duke smith says he
appreciates the hoodie i mean shout out
to you uh
l hunt l144 says bucks celtics
bart 113 says uh
lakers dubs they're back and forth in
the comments they're back and forth in
the comments i'm gonna make a decision
sam i'm gonna put my foot down and i'm
going to make a decision you know when
the comments are all over the place i
gotta gavel up and make a decision here
and i've said we as a family are riding
with the milwaukee bucks boston celtics
3x2 we're riding with you sam we are all
gonna ride uh thanks to our friends over
at fanduel for boosting that
from minus 110 to plus 120 make sure you
guys get on fanduel and take advantage
of that boost
but sam is my favorite part of the show
let's talk major markets money lines
against the spreads and point totals for
tonight's game let's take a look at the
odds sam
look at them ponder them what are you
seeing here and what do you like
yeah i think my biggest lien would be
lakers warriors under
again like the lakers are obviously a
disaster right now no lebron no a.d no
rust tonight they've been eliminated
from the playoffs what do they have to
play for pretty much nothing
they haven't even been playing with much
pride this season anyway as it is so you
tack on obviously the warriors have no
steph to me it just feels like one of
those games where both teams kind of go
through the motions and i think that's
great for an under so we'll roll with
that
sam is rocking with the under i like it
you're rocking with the under in the
ladder game but sam i want to talk about
that first game i want to talk about the
first game
it's up in the air if they're going to
be playing or not but we know boston
celtics they like to focus up on defense
half court offense but we know those
milwaukee bucks they like to run up and
down the court they like to get up and
down and put up a lot of shots a lot of
points
to over under sitting at 227 i'm going
to lean under here i'm going to lean
under here just with all the up in the
air of who's playing who's not playing
i i i want to lean under there and and
and but i want to go to the comments
because i want to see if they're with me
if they're against me if they have other
thoughts uh and i'm in the comments and
indeed geek is in the comments he's
talking about that lakers plus 14
looking pretty nice i mean
yeah it does look pretty nice but the
lakers who who's playing for them sam
that's the question of the day who's
playing for these teams as a lot of
teams are getting ready for the playoffs
uh i see goat garden says over in the
points he's fading us it's okay but he
also sees says lakers money whoa lakers
money line for go garden i got one more
in me uh bad sports takes is agreeing
with you sam it says lakers warriors
under
uh so
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you guys are walking away with shorts
you guys are walking away with those br
batting br betting basketball shorts um
it's all right we talk major market sam
we talked major markets
let's talk player props it's time for
lock or not i'm going to put up a prop
and i need all of you to get in the
comments and tell me whether it is a
lock or not
and you know what we've got the playoffs
starting soon and i am feeling real good
about my golden state warriors
so you know what we're about to talk
some golden state warriors players combo
sam first up is jordan poole he's
forming into his own this season the bet
is for him to have a combined
29
points and assists sitting at -122 sam
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this one
i do i feel like you're gonna agree with
me here greg this just doesn't this just
feel like a jordan pool game
most of your traditional big stars
aren't playing he's been on fire
recently uh we talked about this earlier
right like he's been covering this
number on on points alone on a lot of
these recent games so you tack in the
assist i i wouldn't be surprised at all
if he goes for 30. so i i really like
this one i think this is a fun one
yeah i honestly sam i think this one is
a layup i think this one is a layup
jordan pool uh 29 like you said he's
he's covering this by points alone and
my guy's going to have the ball in his
hands a lot no steph curry still clay
might be on the limit minutes
restriction dre might be on men's
restriction so the ball is going to be
in jordan pool hands a lot tonight i
love this one i'm all over it but let me
get to these comments and see what they
are talking about sam giving away some
hoodies uh
br betting wow they're saying pass on
this the our band is saying pass on this
those are bad vibes all right here we go
easy lock from maddox maddox that's easy
lock he's a he's a bucket uh
our giraffe says jordan pull everything
points assists boards everything i love
that mentality especially with no steph
jojo four three four seven three four
five four jordan pool is getting over 29
with just points that is an easy catch
so the comments are loving this one sam
next up we have draymond green to have a
combined 15
rebounds and assists it's sitting at
-102 sam talk to me and talk to the
people
do you like this one yeah
this one is is tough again like the
lakers are awful and they're not playing
their top guys and i think that leads to
the warriors blowing them out and i
think the warriors are going to manage
draymond green's health again because
he's been out for a bit i don't think
they're going to push his minutes in a
game like this so i think he's gonna
play well i just fear it might be a game
where he plays 20 25 minutes and the
number goes under
right right right
if if this if this said if this was
draymond's assist total i will possibly
feel a little better but we're talking
points rebounds i still think he's
feeling the ailments of the back injury
as far as in rebounds we're seeing his
rebound number take a little dip from b4
and points we know draymond
you know he's that's not what he do
that's not what he's out there to do
he's out there to get the ball to the
playmakers so sam i'm right there with
you i'm going to stay away from this one
but i want to see what the people are
talking about in the comments
let me see uh we're going to have
another we're going to have another
draymond under same game parlay sean
griffin has got the jokes no we're not
going to do that to dre we got sugar
shane zero five one five says no green
is gonna be on a minute's restriction so
he's not rocking with it shout out to
you shane you are walking away with the
hoodie sam let's move on to the last one
because finally we have clay thompson to
have a combined
28 points rebounds and assists
looking at this i think this one is a
layup sam but talk to me talk to the
people are you rocking with this
yeah it's
man it's so tempting because clay i mean
clay is a bucket he could get 28 points
on his own so all you need so you might
not even need the rebounds and assists i
think the concern again is will the
warriors play their veterans full
minutes
especially in a game that doesn't really
matter
probably not
but it's clay
he has been playing more minutes
recently maybe they want to keep him out
there a little bit more just to kind of
let him kind of get going and find his
flow so
i'm not saying it's a lock i'm not
saying i'm it's not i'm curious you're
taking i'm kind of in the middle here i
know that uh i know you know i should
come on with a really strong take but i
don't really have one here i'm curious
for you lee
sam i i i i'm right there with you i i
think this one is just to me it's just
too good to be true i feel like the odds
makers know something they might have
the minutes uh totals that the warriors
are going to do today or they might be
in contact with steve kerr something but
to me this seems like like a layup for
clay thompson 28 points rebounds and
assists combined like he could do he
could just score 30 points and what's an
ease we saw him do it not too long ago
but
i think i want to stay away from this
one sam it's just something in my heart
something in my gut telling me to stay
away from this one hopefully i don't
regret it but let's see what the people
in the comments are talking about they
might be taking this one jojo says clay
is cashing this only on points it's easy
uh
geek says 24 4 and 4 is his guess
shout out to you guys
you guys are walking away with hoodies
all right sam it's time to build the br
betting custom same game parlay which
you yes you can ride along with us on
fanduel tonight we're looking at the
bucks celtics game and i need everybody
to get in the comments and tell me what
they think which legs are locks which
legs are not
sam let's get right to it
first leg of the parlay we are starting
it off with mvp candidate giannis anta
takupo to score 30
plus
points sam next leg of the parlay we got
honest yeah i mean giannis on zakubo to
record 12 plus
rebounds give us your take on the two
legs of the parlay and the honest
yeah i think i think you mentioned it
right i think the thing you have going
in your favor here is giannis is making
a push for mvp um and 30 and 12 is
that's light work for giannis you can do
that in his sleep
i i just there's a little caution of how
many minutes are these guys going to
play again
i think these teams might kind of want
to start positioning themselves for the
three seed over the two seed because the
nets are probably gonna be the seven
seed i don't think anyone wants to play
them in the first round so this is a
really interesting game so i think if
giannis is chasing the mvp and plays 30
35 minutes i think he's getting it um so
i think it's well within range there is
just a little concern that maybe he is
not playing his full complement of
minutes
there is some concern but sam you make a
great point that both of these teams
have to think about
playing those brooklyn nets in the first
round of the playoffs
that's a tough stretch but let's move on
to the next part of the parlay the next
two legs we're talking about chris
middleton to record four plus assists
and sam you know how i feel about
three-pointers made but we're talking
about chris middleton making three plus
three-pointers made talk to me and talk
to the people do you think this portion
of the parlay
can hit
yeah i i will say i do like that we
themed this parlay around the box
because i think that of these two teams
they are more likely to try in this game
it seems like the celtics again just
based on who they're resting really are
kind of trying to get that three seed
they're you know okay dropping this one
where the bucks it does seem like
they're mostly playing their guys so if
i were to you know play the parlor i
would like it to be in the box and again
i think both these numbers middleton
four assists middleton three threes i
think that's well within his range of
normal numbers so i think it's very
possible again it's you just have the
concern of minutes so it can be kind of
a toss-up at times but i think no doubt
that middleton can pull it off
no doubt middleton can pull it off
control room can we show the people
the three plus three pointers made so
they could take a picture possibly in in
and and go put this parlay in there it
is now let's put up the ticket guys
let's put up the ticket so we can show
you guys if you guys will go over to
fanduel and put a hundred dollar bet and
you are walking away with 667.77
[Music]
sam now before i get into these comments
what are you grading the same game
parlay today
i'm giving it a b i think you know again
i'm just gonna repeat myself for the
fourth time because why not uh i think
the concern about how many minutes these
guys are gonna play keeps me from an a
but like i said i do like that we
focused it around the bucks i think if
these guys get their minutes uh they can
get it and a seven to one payout is
pretty nice on something like this so uh
i'm going to be
sam is rocking with b b's definitely
does get degrees uh but i'm in the
comments i am in the comments looking
for takes because i'm giving out shorts
and i'm also giving out some jerseys sam
go sports says middle money maker
talking about chris middleton shout out
to you go sports you're sending those
good vibes uh
appreciate you uh you were walking away
with some shorts of your choice anthony
thompson's throwing a little shade in
there sam he says not feeling this
parlay guess what we're gonna make you
feel the love though we're gonna send
you a jersey of your choice anthony
thompson and hopefully that way you can
feel the love and feel the vibes and
hopefully ride this parlay with us
because we're looking to get rich uh i
got one more in me sam i'm giving away
one more
i see b minus from jojo
b-minus for luck that that's how i know
jojo is a fan of the show when liv gives
us b-minus as we usually hit uh jojo you
are also walking away with a jersey
sam we cannot get out of here
because we know the playoffs start next
week we cannot get out of here without
talking some futures today we asked you
in the app who is your best bet to win
the nba finals i need you to get in the
comments and tell me who you are walking
with let's take a look at the current
odds there they are you see the phoenix
suns up top followed by the milwaukee
bucks
brooklyn my golden state warriors
sitting at a hefty plus 950
boston miami rounded it out sam
what are we thinking about these odds
brother
yeah so
i'm not going to be the person who takes
the favorite uh and takes the suns but i
i just want to give the suns their
flowers because i feel like they
continue to get slept on this has been
the best team in the season by far they
are absolutely incredible they are going
to be such a tough out i feel like this
is absolutely their title to lose now
that chris paul is back healthy they
they really have they really have it all
um so i'm gonna look more towards the
long shots because i
i feel like the teams up close i would
just think the suns are are that team so
i'm gonna take the nuggets at 27 27-1
um
mike malone the nuggets coach has kind
of been hinting that jamal murray might
be back sooner than later he's dropping
comments about the week of rest for the
play-in
gives them some time to get him back and
if jamal murray comes back this next
team is just loaded with him jokic aaron
gordon they they have a lot of talent so
i think at 27-1 throw a flyer i'm
looking at denver
i love it sam sam i love when you throw
darts brother i love when you go through
because you if if the people don't know
my guy sam
is a futures guru he's a futurist guru
he just got done hitting one uh the
other day with the ncaa championship but
i i like that sam i'll i'll jump in here
my heart is what the golden state wears
i'm happy that they're plus 950 but the
thing
is
stephen curry isn't in the lineup and i
know that they're not winning the
championship without stephen curry being
in a lineup so i'm not talking warriors
today i want you guys to look right
above them
and i'm talking about the brooklyn nets
now sam hear me out kyrie irving
kevin durant potentially getting back
ben simmons i just think i just in a in
a seven game series it's gonna be hard
it's gonna be hard to make the
adjustments to be kyrie and kevin durant
whether they're the eight seed seven
seed it does not matter whether home or
away it does not matter
they are they're they're in the position
that they're in according to the odds
makers for a reason sam and they're in
the playing tournament so
they know we know
i can see them pulling this one out if
the golden state warriors is not there
now let me get to the comments
let me get to the comments because i am
giving away
hoodies
uh i see mark van reeve next taping the
championship this year katie kyrie shout
out to you you are walking away with
hoodie and i also see far money 914
curry going for one more
i can see that happening i like those
comments i like those comments those
align right along with what i got going
on but all right sam it's been a hot
topic for a while now and and was
brought back to life after lebron sat
out earlier this week with the lakers
were on the brink of a potential play in
birth do you think star players are
sitting out too much during the season
it's tough i think and i think adam
silver even talked about uh it himself
where he's kind of concerned about how
you know the top guys are are missing
some really important games and and i
think it's tough it's a tough thing to
solve i think silver talked about it are
there too many games i think my my
opinion would be probably especially
with the playing tournament here which i
think has been great it's been very
exciting but it also leads to situations
where the nets can be the ninth or the
ninth team in conference right now and
still have the third best odds to win
the title which kind of almost devalues
the regular season if you can kind of be
a
middle of the road team and still have a
decent chance to win a championship so
uh i do
it's just it's a tough thing to solve
but i think limiting the amount of games
in a season might help i don't know
here's your thoughts
sam that honestly that might be the
solution to take limiting the games
guys won't have to be playing as many
back-to-back back-to-backs uh might be
more fresher legs
but all this is happening because lebron
james sat out and that's just what it is
it's it's when lebron does something
it it it amplifies things but
you guys know what i'm in a giving mood
so i'm going to give away some more
hoodies
uh i'm in the comments right now i see
people the duck says he likes golden
state
shout out to you ryan ko says he wants
the people to play more shout out to you
ryan uh shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you guys are all walking away
with hoodies the dogs are barking that
means the dogs might be barking tonight
uh thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel remember
what you learned today
the three by two is a lot the br betting
same game parlay is a lot and also the
dogs are barking so go take some
underdogs we're switching it up on you
guys next week we'll be back here next
friday giving out more hoodies more
jerseys and more locks if you won a
prize today we will dm you alongside sam
richmond i'm greg ivory go
bet those dogs as you can hear them
barking and we are leaving the group
chat peace
[Music]
[Music]
you